the book ends with cosmic perspective
what is cosmic perspective in Europe
well cuz because it as humans we have
big egos I've never measured your ego I
don't know off the chart yeah you have
prime candidate to have your ego
dismantled by cosmic discovery because
you learn things that disrupt your sense
of self-importance because we think of
our importance as being special and
different so just to give an example in
one centimeter of your lower colon lives
and works more microbes than the total
number of humans who have ever been born
and so we're thinking it's just mine to
like MA
how did you know that it's true is
everybody everybody and so you think
you're in charge of what's going on but
you are to the microbes simply a dark
anaerobic vessel of fecal matter your
existence is both is that to them that's
the lousy estate anyone said to me in at
least two weeks so the point is if you
get them upset then they're in charge
yes they will send you to the bathroom
every 12 minutes right so and then you
realize it's not that you are greater
than these microbes you have a code
dependence on one another you exist
because they do your digesting and they
exist because you provide a vessel for
that to happen so the cosmic that's a
biological cosmic perspective yeah which
puts it in context and in that context
you can't think of yourself as separate
and distinct anymore because that's how
we define being special I'm different
and I'm special and I'm distinct it's we
are special because we're the same we
are one not only with each other but
with the universe itself that's free you
know I just
I have to say I find it
I am always calmed by the notion that
comes up frequently because I was you
know I yeah I have an ego I probably a
big ego but I also have a lot of
self-loathing but but I do I am always
calmed by the notion that things are
much bigger than I am I think more of us
need that in our lives like if I see
like a big mountain or I'm driving out
in the desert and I see a massive
structure you know it's a reality check
I see that and I think that was there a
million years before me it's gonna be
there a million years after me it
doesn't care I don't count in a good way
what yes more than that and this is
everywhere you can read this and it's in
the book of course and we land there in
the last chapter the molecules never get
ya your body's getting over so so the
the atoms in your body are traceable
traceable to stars that have exploded
across the galaxy and spread that
enrichment in two gas clouds that would
later make star systems that have enough
elements like carbon nitrogen and oxygen
elements of life in order to make
planets and life upon it so for me the
deepest cosmic perspective there is is
recognizing that not only are we living
in this universe the universe is living
within us you are so high right now
it's very beautiful but it's just a real
beauty to all of it yeah well good soon
there's a beauty to all of it yeah the
universe
you